Public Sénat en partenariat avec le
Centre national du livre vous présente
au bonheur des livres
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans l'émission
littéraire de Public Sénat au bonheur
des livres nous savons que les femmes
dans l'histoire sont courageux nous le
savons depuis
Judith et oloferme depuis antigone et
Créon à l'époque moderne donnée de
nombreux exemples et si nous en doutions
encore la magnifique insurrection des
femmes iraniennes en administre une
preuve éclatante c'est de cela dont nous
allons parler ce soir dans cette
émission que nous avons intitulé des
femmes combattantes
isolt Williams bonsoir
isole vous êtes journaliste vous avez
dirigé des magazines et vous avez aussi
écrit des biographies et la dernière de
ces biographies consacrée à Marie-Claude
Vaillant-Couturier on l'appelait maiko a
été publié en poche Marie Claude
Vaillant-Couturier c'est une résistante
une déportée une dirigeante du Parti
communiste français
dont chacun des chapitres de son
existence suffir à remplir une vie
entière on va revenir à vous mais on va
commencer avec vous Astrid de l'âge
Astrid vous publiez de la main d'une
femme aux éditions grassées vous avez
déjà publié un recueil de nouvelles vous
avez publié un roman et c'est cette
biographie romancée qui vient de
paraître fait le portrait donc de votre
lointaine cousine
Marie-Anne Charlotte de Corday Darmon
dites Charlotte Corday et qui est passé
à la postérité pour avoir assassiné le
25 messidor de l'an 1 c'est-à-dire le 13
juillet 1793 Jean-Paul Marat on connaît
tous cette figure de l'assassinat
notamment parce qu'elle a fait l'objet
d'un tableau célèbre que tous les
lycéens ont vu alors c'est une héroïne
pour les uns elle est fanatique pour les
autres mais rappelez-nous d'abord qui
est cette jeune et belle Normande de 24
ans au moment où elle assassine marin
ce qui est une aubrotte normande
désargentée mais qui était exactement
d'où vient-elle alors Charlotte Corday
elle vient d'un petit village de
Normandie
le Renoir ou les ligneries la province
et l'ignorerie où elle vivait avec sa
famille
quatre frères et sœurs une mère qui
meurt très jeune et à la mort de sa mère
son père voilà lui demande qu'elle soit
qu'elle aille au couvent elle est admise
à l'Abbaye aux Dames qui accueille des
jeunes filles de bonne famille et à ce
moment-là en fait elle reste assez
longtemps d'ailleurs au couvent
beaucoup plus longtemps que que les
autres qui sont normalement
qui se marient assez jeune mais en fait
elle elle ne souhaite pas se marier et
au moment de la fermeture de du couvent
des couvents elle elle finit par être
accueillie par Madame de Bretteville
donc sa tante à Caen qui est également
votre lointaine cousine voilà en fait on
est apparentés
au 5ème degré on dit donc c'est assez
donc elle a elle est à la sortie de
l'adolescent c'est la révolution on
ferme les couvents et cette jeune femme
qui est issue d'une famille royaliste
une large partie de sa famille émigré
pour rejoindre les armées du prince elle
elle est acquise ou à l'idéal des
lumières elle est favorable à la
révolution mais elle est gérondine elle
est girondines rappelez-nous aussi le
contexte
on est dans cette période de l'histoire
de la Révolution entre ce qu'on a appelé
la première terreur entre disons les
événements du 18 août et les massacres
de septembre et ce qui va devenir la
grande période de terreur au moment du
pouvoir jacobin et elle elle se situe
dans le combat qui oppose la montagne et
la Gironde rappelez-nous ce que c'est
que ce contexte oui parce que en fait à
ce moment là donc
[Musique]
les Girondins donc sont plutôt à la
Convention nationale c'est eux qui
domine et en fait il commence à y avoir
un vent de de révolte parce que
les sans-culottes trouvent que ça ne va
pas assez vite les montagnards donc les
entends d'entendre c'est discrimination
et en fait
il y a une un coup d'État au mois de
juin 1793
qui en fait favorise le la prise de
pouvoir des montagnards et il y a à peu
près 25
Girondins qui sont qui sont proscrits en
fait de
l'Assemblée nationale ils sont tous ils
sont tous favorables à la révolution
mais la Gironde les Girondins ils ont la
droite et la montagne c'est la gauche
c'est ceux qui sont les intransigeants
de la Révolution alors oui tout à fait
c'est les intransigeants enfin c'est ce
qu'on dit les intrants alors après il y
a beaucoup de nuances il y a la plaine
et c'est vrai que les montagnards sont
souhaitent il y a une demande pour une
nouvelle convention qui ne sera jamais
appliquée mais qui est une convention
assez idéale de la République de la
Nouvelle République il faut rappeler que
dans ce contexte la République est en
danger parce qu'elle est attaquée aux
frontières par les par les par les pays
voisins que il y a à l'intérieur du pays
des complots royalistes alors le
personnage sur lequel Charlotte Corday
va concentrer son attention c'est
Jean-Paul marathon donc Jean-Paul Maras
c'est
l'imprécateur de l'elgauche de
l'Assemblée c'est il est à l'aile gauche
de l'aile gauche même il est à l'aile
gauche de la montagne est à l'aile
gauche des Jacobins il est membre du
club des Cordeliers et il a fondé un
journal très populaire dans le Paris
insurgé qui est l'ami du peuple dans
lequel il appelle régulièrement au
massacre des ennemis de la révolution
oui alors c'est vrai que dans l'Ami du
peuple et en fait c'est ce que j'ai
essayé de montrer dans dans mon livre
c'est que
Mara c'est un vraiment un personnage
l'Ami du peuple dans lequel il se cool
pour aller dénoncer
toutes les injustices tous les traîtres
à la à la nouvelle à la Révolution tous
ceux qui sont un petit peu tiède
avec voilà des noms d'oiseaux qui sont
parfois qu'on retrouve d'ailleurs dans
le
dans la nuit du peuple et
oui en fait il est assez radical mais
ensuite il est très radical mais ensuite
il
doit un petit peu mettre en veilleuse si
je puis dire cette radicalité parce que
il est élu
député de la montagne et à ce moment-là
ils ont lui demande de décrire enfin ils
changent le nom de son de son journal et
qui est le public de la République dans
lequel il est un petit peu plus
nuancé si on peut dire mais c'est vrai
que c'est un être enfin c'est un homme
qui
a un idéal très très fort de de la
République alors c'est lui que Charlotte
va cibler elle considère que la raison
pour laquelle on attaque les Girondins
la raison pour laquelle on menace leur
vie la raison pour laquelle on dénature
au fond la Révolution le principal
responsable de ça c'est lui et elle va
l'assassiner par russe vous raconter ça
dans le menu c'est d'ailleurs assez
passionnant de voir comment elle procède
parce qu'elle est moins ingénue qu'on
l'imagine mais au fond d'elle-même elle
considère que c'est légitime qu'elle
fait un tiranicide oui exactement alors
c'est vrai que
tous les
la haine ce cristallise chez les
Girondins surtout les Girondins de Caen
quel côtoient un petit peu autour de ce
Marat qui est
un homme qui est vu par eux comme un
sanguinaire
comme quelqu'un qui va qui va prendre le
pouvoir qui va être le dictateur qui va
être en dictateur et d'ailleurs il a il
a eu un procès il y a un procès qui
essaye de savoir si vraiment il veut
devenir dictateur ou pas mais en fait
non c'est c'est il rentre dans des
personnages de ce couple dans différents
personnages
mais en fait Mara elle a Convention il
est assez
voilà assez effacé en fait c'est surtout
dans ces mots oui qu'il appelle à la au
meurtre on sent vous lisant que parce
que vous faites le récit de Charlotte
Corday de la manière dont elle
assassinemara vous décrivez marin mais
vous racontez aussi l'histoire de votre
propre famille
de des mésalliances des valeurs
aristocratiques maintenues du chant du
roi etc mais en même temps de des
destins étranges par exemple votre Père
qui est qui devient guide de haute
montagne et dans les sont des d'un
milieu d'intellectuel de gauche pose 68
heures enfin il y a des chemins de
traverse mais on sent que vous avez de
l'estime pour marin que son intégrité
c'est un personnage vous racontez son
histoire il a un destin assez un grand
cambolesque lui-même mais vous avez de
la sympathie pour lui vous le dites
d'ailleurs mais vous avez quand même par
rapport à
votre cousine vous la comprenez vous
l'aimez vous partagez ces vues c'est
quoi votre sentiment apostériori vous
vous dites c'est une criminelle ou dite
je comprends cette jeune femme et je
comprends son destin
alors en fait moi au début c'est vrai
que Mara était un inconnu dans cette
histoire et
il m'a vraiment aidé à comprendre déjà
le contexte le contexte dans lequel
Charlotte Corday a agi et il y a eu
vraiment une double dimension à son acte
une dimension politique c'est une femme
qui s'est engagée de manière vraiment
avec une extrême courage et un extrême
une grande inconvisante mais c'est aussi
il y a aussi la dimension sacrificielle
à son acte qui est celui à vrai dire que
j'ai voulu le plus interroger parce que
c'est pas simple d'avoir une telle
figure dans voilà dans sa lignée
familiale lignée de femmes et j'ai voulu
essayer de comprendre en fait pourquoi
ce sacrifice alors à un sacrifice il y a
toujours quelque chose plus grand et je
pense que elle voulait elle elle
cherchait une reconnaissance et ce
sacrifice lui a permis de
d'acquérir cette reconnaissance en tant
que femme mais il y a aussi le fait que
en tant que femme elle était
sa vie était dans un n'avait pas d'issu
et elle était aussi dans une grande
solitude voilà de la main d'une femme
Astrid de l'âge alors
on a fait que fleurer les destins
croisés qui sont tous passionnants
Marie-Claude Vaillant-Couturier donc
vous faites la biographie isolt
c'est à la fois le double de Charlotte
Corday parce qu'elle a son courage elle
a son intransigeance elle a sa droiture
son intégrité et en même temps c'est le
contraire de Sherlock cornet parce
qu'elle elle serait absolument du côté
de Mara quel incroyable personnage quel
incroyable existence elle n'est dans une
famille qui est au cœur dans
l'entre-deux-guerres qui est au cœur de
du milieu intellectuel culturel
artistique parisien la liste des gens
qu'elle croient cette insensée c'est
Gide c'est Picasso c'est Aragon facéty
oui et son père est un personnage lui
aussi hors du commun incroyable Lucien
Vogel qui était on peut dire le grand
inventeur de la presse moderne en France
puisque il a créé vogue en France pour
qu'on dénastes il a créé vu qu'il est
l'ancêtre de Paris Match il a créé la
Gazette du boncton qui était l'un des
premiers magazines de mode le jardin des
modes et j'en passe c'est lui qui a
lancé choisir le photojournalisme c'est
lui qui a fait travailler Robert Capa
quartier Bresson enfin toute la Nouvelle
Objectivité qui venait d'Allemagne de
tous ces Allemands qui fuyaient c'est
lui qui les a fait connaître en les
publiant d'envie voilà donc c'est un
personnage absolument incroyable
on vous raconter sa vie au passage et le
portrait que vous faites de lui on se
sonnait quelques
quel personnage oui alors elle elle naît
dans cette famille plutôt libérale
plutôt progressiste avec beaucoup de
gens de gauche
elle va devenir journaliste mais très
vite animée par un sentiment de justice
et puis par ses voyages dans l'Allemagne
d'abord près nazi puis nazi par ses
voyages en Espagne par la fréquentation
des amis de ses parents elle va devenir
progressivement communiste oui alors
faut quand même ne pas oublier ce
passage en Allemagne qui a été
déterminant où elle a vraiment elle
était étudiante aux Beaux-Arts et elle a
vraiment assisté en direct à la montée
du donc quand elle est rentrée en France
le communisme pourrait l'été la seule
issue et il se trouve que chez ses
parents ou le tout Paris de gauche
venait tous les dimanches
et bien elle a rencontré elle a connu
les gens qui étaient vraiment à la tête
du parti communiste dont Paul
Vaillant-Couturier voilà alors couturier
donc elle rentre elle devient de
militante communiste et elle rencontre
chez ses parents un autre personnage
extraordinaire d'ailleurs on ne peut pas
ne pas penser que il lui rappelle son
père quelque part mais bon bref qui est
de 20 ans qui est de 20 ans son aîné qui
est écrivain journaliste peintre et qui
est surtout l'un des co-fondateurs du
Parti communiste français et l'un des
animateurs du parti et pour lequel et
avec lequel elle va avoir une histoire
d'amour fulgurante même si tragiquement
brève
oui alors elle va donc tomber amoureuse
de Paul Vaillant-Couturier qui a 22 ans
de plus qu'elle ils vont vivre ensemble
elle va prendre sa carte partie elle va
devenir une des on va dire militantes
les plus actives et quand celui-ci va
mourir 15 jours après leur mariage et
bien il y a dans la rue à Paris 500000
personnes pour qui défilent pendant le
l'enterrement de Vaillant-Couturier et
elle elle est propulsée puisque c'est la
veuve Vaillant-Couturier elle devint la
Madone du bolchévisme en France
n'oublions pas que Paul
Vaillant-Couturier c'est quand même lui
qui a écrit et lendemain qui chante
parce qu'il était également compositeur
donc pour elle devient l'incarnation de
désespoir du de toute la ceinture rouge
et puis même du communisme en France
voilà c'est un il est tout ça et en même
temps c'est un grand vivant il l'emmène
dans sa maison de de famille il lui a
pris il lui apprend la vie une vie
très loin de sa vie bourgeoise à elle
enfin et même si il a une enfin ils
n'auront pas complètement avec sa femme
tout ça est sentimentalement complexe
c'est quand même à la fois bref
fantastique et tragique pour elle alors
après la mort de Vaillant Couturier
c'est chacune de ces étapes est
incroyable en 1937 elle s'engage
toujours davantage dans le Parti
communiste français et puis la garrigue
et là elle va rentrer dans la résistance
elle rencontre un autre personnage qui
sera son compagnon pour l'avenir qui est
aussi un des dirigeants du Parti
communiste français mais là elle entre
dans un réseau de résistance elle fait
montre d'un courage inouï et elle va
être arrêtée elle va être arrêtée elle
va être déportée avec des personnages
comme
Daniel Casanova Charlotte Delbo dans les
écrits sont d'ailleurs magnifiques avec
Geneviève De Gaulle elle va être
déportée parmi ses résistants Nuit et
Brouillard ces résistants qu'on envoie à
Auschwitz absolument donc elle se
retrouve dans le fameux convoi des 260
je crois que c'est comme ça qu'on les
appelle donc qui était arrêté non pas
parce qu'ils étaient juste mais parce
qu'ils étaient engagés politiquement
donc elle va se retrouver à Auschwitz et
très rapidement ses compagnes vont
mourir les unes après les autres et elle
va se retrouver propulsée on va dire à
la tête du mouvement de résistance du
Parti communiste au sein
d'Auschwitz et là en fait
elle va bénéficier malgré tout aussi de
du fait qu'elle est elle parle
l'allemand c'est ça qui va lui sauver la
vie parce que rapidement elle va devenir
traductrice pour les capots elle va
travailler à l'infirmerie donc elle
arrive à s'en sortir grâce à sa
connaissance de l'allemand et elle va
également bénéficier d'un statut à part
parce qu'il y a tout un mouvement
international à l'extérieur pour faire
sortir ces femmes qui ont été
emprisonnés à Auschwitz il y a des noms
très connus Paul Vaillant-Couturier est
encore dans tous les esprits donc on la
sort pendant plus ou moins du camp où
elle va quand même vivre dans des
conditions terribles elle va être
envoyée ensuite à Ravensbrück où elle va
passer six mois de plus et quand le camp
est libéré par les Russes et c'est là où
pour moi c'est de l'ordre de la sainteté
elle reste deux mois de plus pour
soigner les mourants alors qu'elle vient
de passer 2 ans en grande concentration
voilà et ça conduite à Auschwitz et
héroïque vis-à-vis solidaire vis-à-vis
de ses camarades elle ne cesse pas de
combattre pendant toute cette période où
cette situation à elle elle manque de
mourir à plusieurs reprises elle rentre
de déportation et là comme vous le dites
c'est comme c'est d'ailleurs comme ça
qu'un journaliste du monde l'appelle
sainte Marie-Claude elle devient
l'égérie du Parti communiste français
elle est non seulement la veuve de
Vaillant-Couturier mais elle est cette
héroïne de la Résistance et de la
Déportation et vous citez d'ailleurs
elle est appelée à témoigner à Nuremberg
ou procès des bourreaux nazis et vous
citez longuement son témoignage qui est
incroyable et remarquable
c'est absolument stupéfiant ce
témoignage que j'ai mis une extinction
parce que il y avait aucune raison de ne
pas le faire raconte de façon absolument
détaillée
clinique ce qu'elle a vécu à Auschwitz
et
c'est absolument enfin c'est
comment en plus elle a cette façon assez
sèche et bourgeoise de s'exprimer il n'y
a pas de elle en fait pas plus que ce
qu'il faut elle est même austère dans sa
façon d'en parler quand elle est remise
en cause par l'avocat des nazis elle le
renvoie dans les cordes et il y a aussi
un élément que qui m'a beaucoup ému
quand elle arrive à Nuremberg il y a
tous les bureaux nazis qui sont là et
elle passe les uns devant les autres et
aller regarde en silence et elle est
fusée du regard et dans le tribunal les
gens pensent qu'il va les frapper et
bien Noël se retourne et elle va
simplement témoigner on a oublié de dire
que c'est une femme d'une grande beauté
d'une beauté scandaleuse idée d'Aragon
et que c'est une femme une femme
élégante que
alors elle a été mannequin il y a tout
de même une ombre au tableau parce que
cette vie est extraordinaire et elle a
failli être
antéonisée elle ne l'a pas été peut-être
pour la raison suivante c'est qu'il y a
une ombre au tableau c'est quel couvre
de son autorité les crimes stalingiens
elle les couvre dans l'entrée de guerre
mais les couvre surtout après après les
révélations le procès kraftchenko et
alors même que ses camarades de
captivité qui ont été à Auschwitz lui
disent tu peux pas faire ça il se passe
là-bas ce qui s'est passé muta discute
indice pour nous et elle va couvrir de
son autorité des crimes saliniens
c'est troublant mais ça s'explique je
pense pour plusieurs raisons d'abord
elle est pas la seule elle est niée on
peut faire la liste de tous les
intellectuels français qui ont suivi la
même route mais je pense que dans le cas
de Marie-Claude il y a deux éléments
supplémentaires 1 elle s'appelle
Vaillant-Couturier l'incarnation de
voilà de lendemain qui chante elle a
passé deux ans qu'on ne concentration
elle a été sauvée par les communistes ce
sont les Russes qui l'ont libéré elle ne
peut pas nier elle peut pas renier ça et
je pense qu'elle s'est engagée et pour
elle de toute façon il n'y a pas pire
que le nazisme mais le communisme ne
peut être que meilleur donc de toute
façon entre les deux pour elle c'est ça
la solution et puis voilà je pense
qu'elle est rentrée aussi en commun ce
comment rentrer en religion et que c'est
extrêmement compliqué c'est une question
de foi et le déni voilà puis aussi
l'idée qu'il y a des dommages
écolatéraux quand on veut faire la
révolution voilà bon bah ça c'est vous
j'imagine que vous vous l'avez bien
religion séculière comme un disait
Raymond Aron on va poursuivre cette
conversation avec une lectrice une jeune
lectrice Estelle qui a une question pour
Astrid je crois Estelle nous vous
écoutons
[Musique]
bonjour à tous donc je m'appelle Estelle
keV je suis étudiante en Master meuf
lettres à l'Université d'Orléans et si
je devais me décrire en tant que
lectrice je dirais que je suis une
lectrice qui apprécie particulièrement
les livres qui vont lier narration
histoire et époque différentes
et comme anecdote de lectrice que je
pourrais vous raconter c'est que je suis
une lectrice qui a toujours aimé les
beaux livres et en particulier les
livres de la Pléiade et un jour en me
rendant chez mes grands-parents j'ai vu
dans un carton un livre de cette
collection et c'est d'ailleurs ce qui a
commencé ma collection que je continue
encore aujourd'hui pour parler du livre
de Madame Astrid de l'âge donc déjà
bonjour à vous ce que j'ai tout
particulièrement apprécié dans votre
livre c'est le fait de lier vos
recherches ainsi que la narration afin
de rendre vivant les recherches que vous
avez pu faire sur Madame Charlotte
Corday
et j'ai aussi tout particulièrement
apprécié l'alternance entre les deux
points de vue c'est à dire votre point
de vue mais aussi le point de vue de
Charlotte Corday
et donc qui nous a plongé dans qui font
qui nous plonge pardon dans deux époques
différentes et la question que je
voudrais vous poser c'est pourquoi
avez-vous choisi d'aller en fait votre
époque et l'époque de Charlotte Corday
et d'avoir fait cette alternance durant
tout votre écrit alors Astrid pourquoi
est-ce que vous alternez de voix la voix
d'aujourd'hui et la voix d'hier la vôtre
et celle de Charlotte parce que je
voulais vraiment
faire cette enquête je voulais
comprendre qui était Charlotte cordée et
j'ai voulu donner au lecteur la
possibilité
de me suivre au cours de cette enquête
c'est à dire ne pas faire seulement une
biographie mais puisque
cette puisque Charlotte cordée était une
parente éloignée j'ai remonté aussi aux
sources de ma famille et donc c'était
important pour moi de donner au lecteurs
c'est de ces deux narration mais je dois
dire que c'est vrai je me suis coulée
dans cette journée du 13 juillet 93 et
j'ai montré tout je suis rentrée dans
tous les personnages pour justement
essayer d'être en empathie avec chaque
personnage et de pas avoir d'idéologie
c'est ça c'est très important pour moi
bon malheureusement cette émission
s'achève quasiment il nous reste une
chose à faire mais qui n'est pas la PUB
désagréable c'est de partager avec ceux
qui nous ont fait le plaisir de nous
suivre un goût de lecture quelque chose
que vous avez et qui vous a plu
attention c'est satisfait ou remboursé
il faut que nos que les lecteurs de ce
que vous allez proposer soit pleinement
comblés par cette lecture ils ont
commencé par vous alors je
recommanderais tout parce qu'il remonte
le magicien ce qui est une biographie
extraordinaire sur Thomas Man et sa
famille de d'un écrivain irlandais qui
s'appelle chrome
Astrid quel livre que vous recommandez
alors moi je recommande un livre qui m'a
beaucoup beaucoup plu l'année qui est
passée c'est une vie clandestine de
Monica Sabolo parce qu'elle fait
vraiment une plongée voilà autour de
cette enquête autour d'action directe et
aussi enquête familiale enfin personnel
plutôt intime
d'entre vous recommande un livre dans la
lignée de ce qu'il a fait lui-même vous
le mélange entre l'enquête familiale et
l'enquête historique et vous la
biographie alors à la rédaction de au
bonheur des livres nous avons choisi
Steven Cléry
mais il a il a fait un roman qui raconte
la vie d'un jeune d'un jeune homme dans
un quartier populaire de Fort-de-France
dans un morne et à travers lui sa
famille écrit dans une langue proche de
la langue parlée pas seulement la langue
parlée à Fort-de-France dans ces
quartiers montre enfin c'est un roman
d'apprentissage dans le style d'ailleurs
des romans d'apprentissage tout à fait
différents c'est le mec qui nerf grande
couronne c'est un roman qui est en
parlant livre de poche et qui avait un
peu choqué parce que c'était l'histoire
d'une adolescente d'une de la grande
couronne donc de la banlieue parisienne
qui découvre ou qui en tout cas
découvrent et la prostitution la
prostitution
occasionnelle c'est un portrait qui est
à la fois glauque qui a-t-on dit à
certains égards mais très très fort de
la vie de de cette jeunesse c'est un
autre roman d'apprentissage je suis sûr
que ça va vous intéresser Tardi et
manchette la position du taux de tireur
couché la position du tiroir couché
c'est le livre chef-d'oeuvre de
manchette qui est le créateur du néopola
Parisien et s'est-il illustré par Tardy
qui est lui aussi l'inventeur du dessin
narratif donc la conjonction des deux
est absente cette bande dessinée est
absolument merveilleuse ça vous
intéresse la bande dessinée vous battre
tout ça c'est recommandé vivement et
enfin
Arthur te goule Arthur Teboul c'est le
chanteur d'un groupe qui s'appelle feu
chatterton très aimé très aimable et
qu'il a publié chez segher c'est-à-dire
dans la maison historique de poésie en
France celle d'Aragon des luards de tant
d'autres
des poèmes il écrit des chansons mais il
écrit des poèmes aussi et ce livre
connaît un grand succès
je sens que l'une et l'autre vous êtes
intéressé par lui et donc pour
ne vous départager je vais le garder
voilà merci à vous c'était
un de mes choix merci à vous deux pour
pour votre présence ici merci pour vos
deux livres qui sont qui racontent des
destins passionnants que nous avons
seulement survolé merci
à Estelle notre lectrice merci à vous
qui nous avait suivi vous pouvez revoir
cette émission sur la plateforme
numérique de Public Sénat public
sénat.fr ou et puis nous allons nous
retrouver la semaine prochaine dans le
même format à la même heure à moins que
d'ici là nous ne nous soyons croisés
dans une librairie merci bonsoir
[Musique]
Sénat en partenariat avec le Centre
national du livre vous a présenté au
bonheur des livres